how's it going guys another little
weekend bonus video i thought i'd just
uh do i think uh
so one of my most popular series on my
channel is my cmake tutorial
thing i you know honestly i just kind of
won this uh and uh did my best to
explain what i knew and for a lot of
these i did a lot of research before you
know doing them
and scripted them and i you know i did
the best i could and uh
so they're not perfect but a lot of
people seem to really appreciate them
but every once in a while someone comes
along and leaves
a hilarious comment and i like
i'll show you what they are in a second
i like to respond to these ones
and ask them
what you know what they've
found that's better this happens every
once in a while so i usually i i you
know i try to respond to all the good
ones or at least heart them or something
but these ones i usually just ask uh
oh cool well thank you i'm glad you
found something better go ahead and
enlighten us let us know what you found
and the response is
you know you just can't help some people
so let's take a look at some of these
because i just think they're funny these
are this is an example of what not to do
like people aren't proud these these
people are gonna have really hard times
getting jobs because
usually when people have when someone
has a really good
criticism of something
if they've got a good answer like
they've got something better you're like
all right cool let's let's hear you out
what do you got that's better
and uh if you don't you don't have
anything you're just a negative critical
person without any better ideas than
what you're criticizing makes you look
really bad so
i guess it's just a lesson of what not
to do all right let's take a look at
some of these all right so here's the
here's the first one i zoom this way and
so you can kind of focus it out cmake is
fluff and garbage never use it on
windows if you are c c plus plus
developer all caps hours of wasted time
and endless errors no matter what you do
well do not use it ever well let's just
address this hours of wasted time and
endless errors no matter what you do
well it's not no matter what you do
you're doing it wrong so there is a way
to get around there is you just need to
do it correctly it's okay that's a false
statement this guy's obviously enraged
very mad
uh whatever you know if you do youtube
videos you kind of get used to these
sort of comments they they happen so you
gotta just thicken your skin and be like
all right now this guy's making a fool
of himself so i politely asked i get
comments like this occasionally on these
videos and i always ask what do you use
instead well it's been well it's only
been a day so it hasn't been that long
no response
nothing he doesn't he doesn't have any
insight for us just
just wanted to let everybody know that
he he doesn't understand cmake and he's
very mad about it and uh no matter what
you do it's gonna have errors but the
reality is he's just doing something
wrong he's making a mistake sure happens
all of us coding can be pretty
frustrating in general when it feels
like you're doing things right but
something's still wrong
it does happen if you're not uh mentally
prepared to handle that
it's possible that coding is not the
right thing for you or
you just need to like accept that
happens sometimes and the worst thing
you can do is make a fool out of
yourself so
take a step back when you feel that way
all right let's let's check out another
great comment ah here we go
c make bad
i just see make that uh these are pretty
rare i had to scroll through a lot of
great comments so thank you for all the
great comments i could even find this
one these are these are i want to say
rare and i'm literally only addressing
them because i think it proves a good a
point it's something that's worth
learning okay so i just respond happy to
hear you found something better please
enlighten us his response
not see make in my opinion yeah i think
we established that from your first
comment
care to enlighten us sent you
since you found something better imagine
interviewing this guy and you tell them
about your tech stack and he says it's
terrible and you and you as the
interview viewer go okay what do you use
that's better he goes not that i think
you just end the interview right and you
say okay get it get out of here
he elaborates a little bit all right
let's check out this elaboration it's
like oh that was a bad answer let me
straighten this out i feel like there's
going to be a cc make which just makes c
make list files
uh what and then after that cc cmg which
makes c c make which makes c make which
makes make file that actually builds the
project
just write the build file
can't be that hard
you feel like there's gonna be
more tools to help handle tools that are
kind of complicated okay
that doesn't answer the question
and no it's not that hard to build a
make file it's a a little more comp
actually quite a bit more complicated
than a cmake file if you ask me
but cmake does more than that i i don't
i don't understand how this uh how this
is what he came to that's it that's what
he left of that i don't even know how to
respond to that i'm just flabbergasted
that that's the answer imagine saying
something like
say you use some video editing tool and
someone says it's terrible and you go
okay what do you use that bet that's
better
and they say
uh not that one
and then you like kind of give them a
confused look so they feel
like they should elaborate and maybe
you're using defense you resolve and
they say that's the one that's terrible
and they go i just i just feel like
there's going to be a da vinci dementia
resolve and then a davinci dementia
davinci resolve and just just use
just just uh go in there
and go into the binary
file of your video and like just
manually
edit it in a text editor
so yeah the lessons don't be like these
people basically okay this one just
confuses me so i need a little help i
it people seem to be upvoting it so i
guess like people are agreeing with it
but
i i still don't get
what it means sir
full video editing tutorial step by step
upload a video i will really see i want
to make a video editor
okay i get to maybe this language is
first language is not english and that's
fine but i still don't understand even
like trying to decipher it think about
it uh you know small grammatical errors
aside
do you want
like an all-in-one how to edit a video
from start to finish and upload it like
everything or
are you asking for like a coding
tutorial about how to program and create
your own video editor
i'm honestly not sure and the more i
read it the more i'm not sure but it's
got up votes
so and they're not for me so
someone someone wants it can can you
guys maybe uh
help me on this one
what he's asking for
or what people are asking for because
i'm not
i don't get i don't get this one but uh
i'll try i digress and i scroll and i
scroll
ah here we go here's another one that's
a bit critical understand the basics
yeah as every command doesn't work it
doesn't seem to be the basics to see
make as you pretend just the command
make
doesn't work you try to launch cmake
well you gotta you gotta go to the
directory
i don't know if i said that in this one
or not but you can't you know make
doesn't magically navigate through all
your directories
finding your make file you got to go to
the directory where your make file was
and then type make so
maybe you're doing that wrong then you
launch cmake dash b but for me it does
nothing
okay that's just build directory you got
to give it a build directory and you got
to point to your source so that's what
the dash s is uh but uh
i'm guessing he's just doing it all
wrong and not actually paying attention
so i i don't know so i've responded with
seems to work okay for most people i
don't know if your setup is different or
if you're doing something wrong always
hard to tell with comments like this but
best of luck to you as a response the
main problem of your video is that we
need to pre-configure our computer with
some tool sets like main gw64 or clang
or cmake or use uh main 32
make instead but
because it's not by default supported by
window all right
yeah this
i guess maybe
maybe right maybe we need a little a
pre-video one that says how to set up
your computer for c making every
different possible combination of
compilers out there
that you could possibly use with c make
ever that's that's a ridiculous video to
make and i simply can't do it without i
don't know days and days of research and
me going to friends and say hey can i
borrow your mac so i can figure this out
on mac let me go install on linux on the
new computer to get it all set up and
test here record there put it all
together
to do what he's asking here
is like
80 hours of work
yeah set up your environment
do some basic google searches on how
cmake works in that particular
environment and adapt accordingly
it's uh way easier than me trying to
make
a video that covers every single
possible different option it's kind of a
ridiculous request i understand you're
frustrated but my god settle down
just you know pick your compiler and
stick with your thing and if you switch
it
you know stick with that thing for a
while it's
i don't feel like this is as big of a
deal as some of these people are making
it out to be yeah so i after a while i
didn't really know how to respond to
this person but uh
someone chimed and said hey if you
actually want to program c on windows
there are other tool sets uh this is
basically linux or os linux you can use
windows subsystem for linux and wsl for
that sure
yeah there are a million different
options and you just kind of gotta pick
one and
try it out i've tried a lot out in the
past but uh you you've seen my recent
videos of coding and stuff you know what
i tend to stick with now but there's no
reason i couldn't switch back to the
other one but
there's a ton of them i've never tried
but i've seen
work okay and i'm sure i could adapt to
them if i need to
i'm not sure how
my answer helps there but i just just
kind of throw that out there all right
and let's see they respond yeah it works
but it's got some issues
i didn't have a virtual i didn't have
with a virtual machine
okay yeah you definitely got to do some
adaptations for
your particular compiler environment
that's that's like i said a very
complicated
subject uh
but if you narrow it down to say okay
what am i using currently how does c
make work with this
it simplifies it a lot so maybe i could
start making sets of videos that like
are for each individual setup uh
i could probably start
plugging away at that you know kind of
one at a time rather than trying to do
an all-in-one
because you know each individual i could
probably do in
a lot less time
but
i just don't feel like it's very
necessary it's the thing because uh
well maybe it is i i guess i don't know
how to solve circular dependencies of
big projects um
well
generally
yeah it's hard to answer without
specific examples but actually this came
up several times in my latest series so
maybe maybe you've seen that um if
you're using a lot of header only stuff
you've got to be real careful about
what order you include stuff in make
sure you're putting pragma once at the
top of your files
and uh i don't know
give me a specific example and i'll
probably be able to tell you all right a
few others uh came out here so i made
a video you know the visual studio about
the the bug it's it's sort of i don't
know i kind of discovered it's
it's more like a miscommunication than a
bug you know they got a search that says
it searches all your files and inside
files and it just simply doesn't but
there is a way to actually do that with
visual studio so
uh yeah and i thought i explained that
pretty clearly in the video and in the
uh update but uh someone says 2022 is
definitely worse as visual studio 2022
it's like a triple a game but for coding
absolutely riddled with development
halting bugs and you should not be there
to begin with and it's not an open
source you can't fix that that has not
been my experience bugs i found a few
maybe oddities but nothing i couldn't
work around
with a little bit of not much like i
just streamed today and i had to figure
out for unit tests how to make
uh your working directory the same as
the test
directory because oddly enough it
doesn't set to that automatically so you
got to make this weird macro but
i i didn't find i don't find 2022 to be
worse in any way i don't see how it's
worse it seems maybe a little better
and so i just simply asked i hear you
but do you have any documented examples
or proof
um well someone actually responded i
didn't notice this
at first i thought you're talking about
the actual year not the ps version
ah here's a funny one this guy must have
been bitter
thanks for the huge
volume music at the end
welcome i guess that you know you can
stop the video or pause it or turn it
down or skip it
and there's there's plenty of fair
warning i put text up before it said hey
i'm going to play this song out and it
slowly increases in volume
and it's a sweet song so
maybe you're just bitter
all right so i'm having actually a hard
time finding any more uh negative or
critical comments i'm trying to
mostly kind of just knock those out in
this video because i think the in
general those are more
interesting for you guys to hear my
response on than me just saying thanks
over and over but i really do appreciate
the good comments and i try to let you
guys know that as much as i can when you
leave them so uh i just really
appreciate you guys support and uh hope
you enjoyed this video
it's uh
this is going to come out as a bonus
video i don't know how to
come out with something like this so
thanks for watching hope you guys have a
good one peace out